eine ansprache in schwieriger zeit wegen
der korona pandemie wendet sich
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel an die
bevölkerung wir müssen auch wenn wir so
etwas noch nie erlebt haben zeigen dass
wir herzlich und vernünftig handeln und
so leben retten
es kommt ohne ausnahme auf jeden
einzelnen und damit auf uns alle an
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster ein außergewöhnlicher
appel und damit willkommen bei den heute
nachrichten vom mittwoch in einer woche
in der sich die ereignisse überschlagen
und vieles zum ersten mal passiert
so wendet sich erstmals in ihrer
amtszeit angela merkel im fernsehen
direkt an die nation
sieht man von den alljährlichen
neujahrsansprachen mal ab in gänze zu
sehen gleich nach dieser sendung und sie
versucht mut zu machen in einer
situation wie es sie noch nie gegeben
hat hierzulande frank buchwald selten
nur wenden sich kanzler direkt ans volk
heute nun angela merkel corona gibt den
ton an
es ist ernst nehmen sie es auch ernst
seit der deutschen einheit
nein seit dem zweiten weltkrieg gab es
keine herausforderung an unser land mehr
bei der es so sehr auf unser gemeinsames
solidarisches handeln ankommt keine
therapie bisher keine impfung deshalb
gelte es risiken zu begrenzen
wir sind nicht verdammt die ausbreitung
des virus passiv hinzunehmen wir haben
einen mittel dagegen
wir müssen aus rücksicht voneinander
abstand halten
der unnötige begegnung vermeidet hilft
allen die sich in den krankenhäusern um
täglich mehr fälle kümmern müssen so
retten wir leben das wird für viele
schwer und auch darauf wird es ankommen
niemanden allein zu lassen sich um die
zu kümmern die zuspruch und zuversicht
brauchen
die kanzlerin dankte ärzten und
krankenschwestern sie kümmerten sich um
die schwer kranken das sind nicht
einfach abstrakte zahlen in einer
statistik sondern das ist dein vater
oder großvater eine mutter oder
großmutter eine partnerin oder partner
es sind menschen und wir sind eine
gemeinschaft in der jedes leben und
jeder mensch zählt menschen die sich
sorgen um ihren arbeitsplatz machen gibt
merkel ein versprechen
ich versichere ihnen die bundesregierung
tut alles was sie kann um die
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen ab
zu federn und vor allem um arbeitsplätze
zu bewahren
einschränkungen der freiheit drastischer
schritt in der demokratie aber ohne
alternative
lassen sie mich versichern für jemanden
wie mich für die reise und
bewegungsfreiheit ein schwer erkämpftes
recht waren sind solche einschränkungen
nur in der absoluten notwendigkeit zu
rechtfertigen eindringliche worte und
ein appell an uns alle in einer krise
deren ende bisher nicht in sicht ist
unser berliner korrespondent theo koll
hat die rede schon gehört theo das
klingt ja wirklich ernst ja und ich
glaube das sollte es wohl auch wenn die
kanzlerin sätze sagt wie es ist ernst
nehmen sie es auch ernst dann ist es
einerseits eine offene und ehrliche
beschreibung der lage aber es ist
natürlich zugleich auch eine art
strategische appel
denn sie versucht klarzumachen dass wir
selbst und unser sozialverhalten unser
abstand halten das wirksamste mittel
gegen die pandemie sind dass es jetzt
auf jeden einzelnen und damit auf uns
alle ankommt und dass insbesondere
wirtschaftlich die nächsten wochen noch
schwerer werden also ja die rede ist wie
die lage ernst
für die bundeskanzlerin ist diese
ansprache er ein ebenso ungewöhnliches
wie ungewohntes mittel will merkel damit
ein ganz neues zeichen ihrer präsenz
setzen ganz eindeutig sie hat ja zu
beginn der korona krise des öffentlichen
management weitgehend dem
gesundheitsminister überlassen
spätestens aber mit dieser rede an die
nation ist klar dass angela merkel sich
auch sichtbar wieder an die spitze setzt
und sie erklärt das regierungshandeln
hier ist ja häufig vorgeworfen worden
dass sie das viel zu wenig macht nach
dem heutigen tag kann man das in puncto
corona nicht mehr sagen und es dürfte
auch nicht das letzte gewesen sein was
wir von ihr zu diesem thema hören werden
vielen dank für ihre einordnung t um die
vollständige ansprache der
bundeskanzlerin sehen sie direkt im
anschluss an diese heute -sendung und
auch auf heute de können sie die rede
verfolgen und auch nachlesen
die infektionszahlen steigen bei uns
weiter an mehrmals täglich werden die
daten von der us amerikanischen johns
hopkins
universität aktualisiert bislang haben
sich soweit nachgewiesen 11.300 zwei
menschen angesteckt im vergleich zum
sonntag ein anstieg um mehr als 140
prozent
die zahl der toten hat sich in den
vergangenen drei tagen von 11 auf 27
erhöht
david sauer berichtet täglich um 10
informiert der chef des robert koch
instituts über die korona lage doch es
ist das gegenteil von routine denn jeden
tag aufs neue scheint die
herausforderung für gesundheitssysteme
und bevölkerung größer steigen die
fallzahlen schneller wenn wir es nicht
schaffen die kontakt unter den menschen
wirksam und über einige wochen
nachhaltig zu reduzieren
dann ist es möglich dass wir in zwei bis
drei monaten bis zu 10 millionen
infizierte in deutschland haben mit
einer entsprechenden erheblichen
überlastung des gesundheitswesens
kontakte so weit wie möglich reduzieren
seit wochen wird darauf gedrängt
notfalls jetzt per verordnung als
bundesweit erster ort hat mitterteich im
nordosten bayerns nun eine
ausgangssperre verhängt
das virus hatte sich dort zuletzt
besonders schnell verbreitet um
bundesweit zu prüfen ob die bürger sich
tatsächlich weniger bewegen analysiert
das rk jetzt handy daten der telekom
anonymisierte bewegungsprofile der
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte kälber hält
das für vertretbar vor allem unter den
aktuellen umständen ebenfalls nur unter
den aktuellen umständen denkbar ist das
was sie an der essener uniklinik machen
verwaltungsmitarbeiter sogar gärtner
schneidern dort aus laken und kitteln
atemschutzmasken für nicht medizinisches
personal reinigungskräfte zum beispiel
das gesundheitswesen muss improvisieren
um mehr möglich zu machen als bislang
möglich ist studierende ausbilden ärzte
aktivieren wenn sie auch jetzt im
ruhestand gibt wir müssen die kapazität
der beatmungs plätze in deutschland
maximal erhöhen
in berlin wird dazu auf dem messegelände
ein krankenhaus für bis zu 1000 bewohner
patienten gebaut
in zusammenarbeit mit der bundeswehr
drastische maßnahmen auch bei der
schlüsselindustrie der deutschen
wirtschaft nach vw audi opel und daimler
hält jetzt auch bmw die produktion
herunter in allen werken in europa und
südafrika stehen die bänder bis zum 19
april still
auch finanziell ist die korona krise ein
stresstest für viele bürger immer mehr
beschäftigte bekommen nur noch
kurzarbeitergeld andere können nicht zur
arbeit weil sie sich um kinder oder
pflegebedürftige kümmern müssen
irgendwann sind überstunden und
urlaubstage aber aufgebraucht was tun
wenn der arbeitgeber dann nicht mehr
zahlt arbeitsminister heil hat sich
deshalb mit arbeitgebern und
gewerkschaften zusammen gesetzt und
finanzielle hilfe versprochen
patricia wiedemeier berichtet nicoletta
miller ist inhaberin eines kinderbuch
ladens in münchen
sie befürchtet dass sie eine schließung
des ladens nicht verkraften wird durch
den online-handel sei es für buchläden
eh schon schwer genug seien von monat zu
monat und denn jetzt kein umsatz machen
weiß ich nicht wichtige mieter zahlen
soll damit geht es los und dann habe ich
natürlich verantwortung für die
mitarbeiter
sie ist nur eine von vielen die derzeit
um ihre existenz und um ihre mitarbeiter
bangen politik gewerkschaften und
arbeitgeber suchten heute nach lösungen
auch für kleins selbständige und für
eltern die ihre kinder betreuen müssen
die frage inwieweit man auch mit direct
zuschüssen mit härtefallregelungen mit
überlegungen die mietzahlungen zu
bewältigen sind wenn keine einnahmen an
stehen all das muss in den nächsten
tagen geklärt werden für größere
unternehmen wurden bereits neue regeln
für kurzarbeit beschlossen
demnach werden den arbeitgebern die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge in voller
höhe erstattet arbeitnehmer bekommen 60
prozent des ausgefallenen
tolles arbeitnehmer mit kind 67 prozent
wir haben gerade bereiche wo die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer die
menschen mit mittleren geringeren
einkommen mit 60% lohnersatzleistung
ganz schnell in die knie gehen das kann
keiner wollen wir haben festgestellt
miteinander dass wir jetzt zügig die
rückwirkend in kraft gesetzten regeln
zur kurzarbeit brauchen und wir werden
auch gemeinsam lösungen finden um lohn
lücken in diesem bereich abzufedern
die opposition begrüßt die bisherigen
maßnahmen das sei aber nicht genug
was muss jetzt mit nachdruck dafür
gesorgt werden dass nicht kleine
selbstständige freelancer ihre existenz
verlieren
nicoletta müller mit ihrem buchladen ist
ein beispiel für die die auf hilfe des
staates angewiesen sein werden
die regierung will helfen mit viel geld
trotzdem reagieren die finanzmärkte
skeptisch frank bethmann an der
frankfurter börse die anleger sind also
weiter verunsichert ein ende der
talfahrt ist wohl gar nicht absehbar
oder ja da gibt es den anlegern wie
vielen bürgern so lange nicht klar ist
wann wieder licht am ende des tunnels
sein könnte will keiner was riskieren
und so erleben wir derzeit etwas was
typisch ist für diese krise wer unsicher
ist der verkauf seiner aktien und wartet
ab
ebenso geht es in vielen ladenbesitzern
den selbständigen den vorständen großer
unternehmen sie alle wissen nicht wann
und wie es weitergeht die autoproduktion
in europa ist praktisch völlig zum
erliegen gekommen wer kauft heute noch
ein auto die vollbremsung zeigt das
ganze ausmaß der verunsicherung jetzt
muss alles dafür getan werden dass auf
die vollbremsung keine pleitewelle folgt
das erste unternehmen trotz krise wieder
investieren und es schnell wieder
aufwärtsgeht stand heute ist der weg
zurück zur normalität aber noch ein
weiter trotz aller zusagen und
konjunkturpakete die jetzt gerade
geschnürt werden
danke für den ausblick frank corona
lähmt gewerbe und industrie auf den
feldern dagegen wächst und gedeiht alles
nur wer all das ernten soll rhabarber
spargel erdbeeren und vieles andere
das steht in den sternen denn die
meisten saison arbeiter die sonst vor
allem aus osteuropa kommen bleiben
daheim
weil grenzen schließen und viele in
diesen krisenzeiten bei ihren familien
wollen wie schwierig das für die bauern
hier ist zeigt alexander hettich ein
paar helfende hände aus bulgarien sind
vor ort doch es reicht bei weitem nicht
landwirt simon klein aus dem rheinischen
dormagen hat nicht einmal halb so viele
erntehelfer wie sonst um diese zeit
dabei ist der rhabarber schon erntereif
und bald der spargel
ich schaue in eine dramatische zukunft
weil wir sind jetzt noch in der vor
saison wir fangen jetzt an die ersten
stangen zu ziehen
aber die haupternte wird nächste woche
beginnen und wir sind jetzt eine truppe
von aktuell 24 leuten und es wird
natürlich schwierig mit dieser truppe
die gleiche arbeit zu bewerkstelligen
statt 24 bräuchte er mindestens 55
helfer verfolgt das gemüse auf den
feldern
viele bauern treibt diese sorge um wegen
der geschlossenen grenzen fehlen aber es
kräfte aus osteuropa einheimische sind
für 9 euro mindestlohn kaum zu finden
für diesen job
die betriebe stehen zurzeit wirklich mit
dem rücken an der wand die haben
erhebliche finanzielle vorleistungen
erbracht dass sie haben die bestände
über ein jahr gepflegt um sie jetzt
bewerten zu können
die haben jungpflanzen geordert die auf
den höfen stehen dir unbedingt auf die
felder müssen
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerin julia
klöckner will kräfte aus anderen
branchen für die landarbeit motivieren
etwa kellner aus den geschlossenen
gastronomiebetrieben landwirt klein
sucht lieber mittels facebook aufruf
nach helfern da geht was
glücklich schätze ich mich dass ich so
viele studenten und schüler weil mir
gemeldet haben die unbedingt jetzt bei
uns arbeiten möchten
ja das tun wir jetzt alles gerade
aufnehmen und dann werden auf jeden fall
diese leute auch kurzfristig eingestellt
doch wie viele kräfte lassen sich so
mobilisieren 300.000 erntehelfer
brauchen die bauern bundesweit und das
schnell
seit dem wochenende ist die grenze nach
polen für ausländer weitgehend dicht die
folge der kontrollen extrem lange staus
nun hat die polnische regierung weitere
übergänge geöffnet wo sonst nur
fußgänger ins land kommen dürfen jetzt
auch autos die grenze überqueren
das ziel die staus endlich auflösen
auf der a4 bei görlitz etwa herrschte
rund 60 kilometer weit stillstand bis zu
30 stunden mussten die menschen hier
warten
helfer versorgten sie mit dem nötigsten
in der ganzen eu gilt ja nun ein
einreiseverbot für nicht-eu-bürger
und was das für reisende bedeutet die
schon hierher unterwegs waren zeigt sich
am frankfurter flughafen
dort hat die bundespolizei heute
passagiere von rund 100 flügen
kontrolliert und mehr als 150 personen
die nicht in der eu lebten die einreise
verweigert sie waren schon in der luft
als das einreiseverbot verhängt wurde
die jeweiligen fluggesellschaften müssen
die betroffenen nun wieder ausfliegen
das corona virus hat auch frankreich
fest im griff
bereits seit gestern gilt eine
allgemeine ausgangssperren keine spur
mehr von pulsierenden großstadtleben die
straßen wie leergefegt wer jetzt noch
raus will braucht einen triftigen grund
denn in frankreich kommen auf 7000 661
infizierte bereits 148 tote
die regionen grauen test an der
deutschen grenze ist ein besonderes
risiko gebiet allein in os zuletzt 30
todesfälle intensivstationen sind
zunehmend überlastet
crystal hat es ist die antwort auf den
hilferuf der ärzte in der mühlhausener
klinik werden die ersten corona
patienten zum flughafen gebracht dort
ist ein fliegendes hospital der
französischen armee gelandet ausgerüstet
für katastrophen und intensiv fälle
es bringt die erkrankten nach
südfrankreich eine notmaßnahme weil in
mühlhausen nichts mehr gießen das ist
für uns sehr wichtig denn so werden
betten frei für die vielen neuen
patienten gekommen
drei viertel der frei gewordenen betten
sind schon wieder belegt krankenhäuser
am anschlag auch in colmar zu viele
patienten es fehlen desinfektionsmittel
diese flaschen hat der notfallarzt aus
den wahllokalen der letzten woche
zusammengesucht notstand seit drei
wochen arbeiten ärzte und pfleger rund
um die uhr wir müssen pausenlos
hochkonzentriert sein
wir alle sind körperlich und psychisch
erschöpft
die regierung kommt es gilt als corona
zentrum auslöser der hohen
infektionsraten war offenbar ein treffen
in der evangelischen gemeinde von
mühlhausen im februar 2000 menschen aus
ganz frankreich waren anwesend viele
haben sich hier angesteckt
wir haben nicht alle teilnehmer
kontaktieren können weil wir ihre
adressen nicht haben wir haben die
mitteilung auf unserer internetseite
veröffentlicht mehr können wir nicht tun
jetzt geht die angst um und das virus
die französische armee wird in den
nächsten tagen entfällt lazarett so wie
dieses hier in mülhausen aufstellen um
die kritischen fälle zu behandeln und
die krankenhäuser zu entlasten
aus london kommt derweil eine kehrtwende
in der korona politik auf die pandemie
reagierte premierminister boris johnson
zunächst demonstrativ gelassen
nun werden seine empfehlungen strenge
keine pub besucher mehr von zu hause
arbeiten überhaupt sozialkontakte meiden
ab freitag bleiben auch schulen und
kitas geschlossen denn auch in
großbritannien gehen die zahlen rasant
nach oben 2642 infizierte 72 menschen
starben
trotzdem mit verboten und schließungen
hält sich die regierung weiterhin zurück
auf der insel ist alles ein bisschen
anders als sonst wo in europa das ist
nicht erst seit dem break bekannt in
großbritannien kommt das öffentliche
leben auch allmählich zum erliegen
selten hat man die weltstadt london so
menschenleer gesehen doch die maßnahmen
erfolgen später und sind weniger radikal
als in anderen ländern
schulschließungen wird es erst ab ende
dieser woche geben wie der
bildungsminister auch erhöhten druck von
besorgten eltern heute bekannt gab
die maßgabe sozial abstand zu wahren
gilt erst seit anfang dieser woche
reisebeschränkungen gibt es erst seit
gestern auf das richtige timing komme es
an so die nachricht von premierminister
johnson bei den pressekonferenzen stets
flankiert von den beiden
verantwortlichen medizinischen und
wissenschaftlichen experten
doch es gibt durchaus kritik am londoner
weg auch von seiten
fachleuten die britische politik ist
besorgniserregend da verkünden sie
irgendwann kurzfristig dass sie aufhören
wollen zu testen das ist verrückt dass
wird die epidemie nicht verlangsamen
sondern beschleunigen und wir werden die
selbe situation haben wie in italien
inzwischen werden die test anstrengungen
verschärft die verantwortlichen sind
überzeugt von ihrem vorgehen
viele verweisen auf die situation in
deutschland italien frankreich und
spanien die sich aber an anderen stellen
der epidemie kurve befinden mehrere
wochen voraus ich denke wir haben die
richtigen entscheidungen zur richtigen
zeit getroffen ob die briten recht
behalten wird sich wohl frühestens in
einigen monaten weisen in die usa dort
könnte sich die auswahl eines
präsidentschaftskandidaten bei den
demokraten noch einige wochen hinziehen
denn wegen der korona krise sind die
nächsten vorwahlen erst einmal
verschoben
gestern wurde aber noch abgestimmt und
ex vizepräsident biden konnte seinen
vorsprung offenbar deutlich ausbauen
laut prognosen der us ende siegte er in
allen drei vorwahlen in florida arizona
und illinois
der einzig verbliebene konkurrent des
senders hat damit nur noch rechnerische
chancen senders will nun seine bewerbung
überdenken
dass die geheimdienste nicht nur in den
usa vor dem 11 september 2001 fehler
gemacht haben ist bekannt
jetzt belegt ein dokument das dem zdf
vorliegt dass auch beim
bundesnachrichtendienst offenbar ein
hinweis versichert ist so ging die
information verloren das sich araber in
den usa als flugschüler angemeldet
hätten unter verdächtigen umständen
elmar theveßen mit den hintergründen
nine eleven angriff auf amerika hinweise
auf die terrorpläne gab es offenbar auch
beim deutschen bundesnachrichtendienst
das geht aus neuen dokumenten hervor die
dem zdf jetzt vorliegen demnach hatte
der bnd schon im jahr 2000 beim
ausspähen der regierung italiens eine
warnung des italienischen geheimdienstes
aufgefangen und entschlüsselt sie
landete in dieser bnd zweigstelle
in heilbronn bei einer sprachexperte so
hat eine linguistin eine nachricht
aufgefangen aus diplomatischen verkehren
die italiener die besagte dass junge
araber in den vereinigten staaten eine
flugausbildung aufnehmen sollten
geld spielt keine rolle und es ging auch
nicht um starten oder landen sondern nur
um geradeaus fliegen
die brisante meldung landete beim bnd
bei der eu-partner italien jene
verschlüsselungs geräte der schweizer
firma crypto ag nutzte in denen die
amerikanische cia und der deutsche
bundesnachrichtendienst hinter türen
eingebaut hatten das zdf berichtete im
februar über details der operation
ruhiger aber der bnd reagierte im jahr
2000 nicht auf die warnung aus italien
die sprachexperten hatte einen teil der
nachricht übersehen entgegen der dienst
internen anweisung hat sie eine so
brisante meldung nicht ihrem
gruppenleiter vorgelegt sondern es ins
wochenende gegangen
gegenüber dem zdf lehnen bnd und
bundesregierung jede stellungnahme ab ob
und was damals unternommen oder
unterlassen wurde und so bleibt die
frage offen ob man vorher mehr hätte tun
können um dann die level zu verhindern
eine ausführliche doku über die
operation rubicon können sie um 20 uhr
15 sehen auf zdfinfo und ab sofort in
der mediathek nach dem rassistischen
anschlag von hanau hatte die
bundeskanzlerin einen ausschuss gegen
rassismus und rechtsextremismus
angekündigt heute wurde er vom kabinett
formel 1 gesetzt
die beteiligten ministerien sollen
bereits geplante schritte gegen
hasskriminalität begleiten
außerdem geht es um strategien wie man
rechtem gedankengut besser vorbeugen
kann
nach der verschiebung der fußball
europameisterschaft ins nächste jahr hat
sich der deutsche bundestrainer tief
bewegt über die korona pandemie geäußert
die welt erlebe einen kollektiven
burnout so joachim löw in einer video
konferenz des deutschen fußball bundes
die verlegung der em sei eine völlig
richtige und alternativlose entscheidung
die nationalmannschaft spendet im zuge
der korona krise 2,5 millionen euro für
soziale zwecke
ohne die vielen helfer in krankenhäusern
praxen und auf der straße würde in
diesen tagen nichts mehr gehen
anlass auch mal danke zu sagen in köln
klingt das so applaus von den balkonen
jubel aus offenen fenstern für die
vielen menschen die sich um kranke
kümmern und sich für die gesundheit und
sicherheit alle einsetzen
eine aktion nach italienischem vorbild
mit der auch die kölner zeigen wir
halten zusammen
tröstlich dass es sogar in diesen tagen
dinge gibt die trotz allem wie gewohnt
stattfinden die ziehung der lottozahlen
zum beispiel die gewinnzahlen lauten 13
19 22 28 31 34 und die superzahl 5
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
und auch das wetter bleibt weiter
wichtig in der nordhälfte wird es nass
im süden sonnig und warm
zu den einzelheiten gleich gunther
tiersch das war es von uns danke für ihr
interesse
marietta slomka mit dem heute journal um
drei viertel 10
und jetzt gleich hier geht es jetzt
weiter mit der rede der bundeskanzlerin
ihnen noch einen schönen abend bis
morgen
[Musik]
könnte bliebe zuschauer in
norddeutschland sind die störche wieder
zurück aber dort wird eher kühler im
süden behalten wir das warme und sonnige
wetter zweiteilung denn über der küste
liegt dieses wolken bahn doch über den
ort sie mit leichtem regen und es tränt
eben diese wärme hier über
süddeutschland von kühlere luft die
jetzt den norden streift und samstag da
rutscht uns diese kühle luft dann runter
bis zu den alpen ja heute nacht leichter
regen an der küste zum teil werden auch
im norddeutschen tiefland sonst gibt's
nebelfelder in süddeutschland und
frostig wird höchstens mal ein bisschen
an den alpen morgen wird es trüb seien
erstmal in norddeutschland zeitweise
regnet es auch immer wieder das ganze
zieht aber weiter nach süden dann
lockert hierauf an den küsten und die
sonne kommt raus der wind weht nur
schwach aus nord west oder nord ost aber
südlich des mains damit wieder das ist
meist sonnige wetter vor allen dingen
richtung alpen und es ist ja nicht nur
sich sondern auch warm von sachsen bis
baden württemberg sind es meist so
zwischen 16 und 21 grad kühler im norden
mit etwa 8 bis 15 grad
ja es geht noch ein bisschen kühler
wechselhafter dann am freitag und
süddeutschland mit schauern und
gewittern und am wochenende ist es
deutlich kühler es schneit dann am
samstag auch das 500 meter runter aber
es wird halt auch immer sonniger ich
wünschen noch einen schönen abend und
machen sie's gut